abbotson news is which has been breaking
this morning
30 people are reported to be missing
following the collapse of houses during
heavy rain
in the town of schultz in western
germany uh let's bring in our
correspondent shingi maruriki who's been
following the story
just bring us up to date with the latest
30 lives lost
sorry that number of lives six lives
lost so far 30 missing
and we wonder whether that might well
rise over the course of the morning
yes morning now so the situation is
still unfolding
but these are once in a generation
floods that have hit
west germany and we're hearing reports
as you say
that six people have died and a further
30 are missing it's not known whether
that's all part of the
same incident but the detail is is truly
alarming two firefighters have drowned
and the army were deployed yesterday to
help in the region and
as you can see from those pictures their
cars upturned
the area completely flooded by this
deluge of
rain water around 25 more buildings
are in danger of collapsing in the
district we know a family of five
according to local news reports are in a
property completely
surrounded by water and people in cities
and towns nearby have
now been told to evacuate because of the
poor weather with the german weather
service putting in place
a severe weather warning for peak for
free parts of three separate
german states um so widespread travel
disruption
people's lives have been lost and more
weather
more bad weather on the way it's
certainly not a not a good situation